[Musique]
à conches et messieurs dames approché
pour découvrir ce baptiste originale la
création de génération lully et sur
scène la conclusion de neuf mois de
travail initié par le centre de musique
baroque de versailles
on les a vu grimper en quinze jours
d'une façon spectaculaire et c'est un
travail qui leur a été demandé tous les
jours où ils ont chanté dansé vous ont
découvert les costumes le décor
l'orchestré les chanteurs etc où se sont
mêlés avec les autres groupes de trappes
et je pense que là le
la mayonnaise a commencé à prendre deux
heures hebdomadaires pour raconter
l'histoire des farceurs ces artistes qui
contournait les interdits royaux sur
scène près 250 chanteurs comédiens et
danseurs des professionnels des
collégiens et des associations
trappistes et je me suis dit de le faire
parce que c'est les trucs comme ça on ne
fait pas ça tous les jeux vous pouvez
donc me suis dit peut-on faire on a
beaucoup appris à danser ça c'est pas
c'est rare quand on danse et tout ça est
alors que les théâtres ont fait tout le
temps à l'école avec les coupes de
france et dès que j'ai commencé à faire
les grandes répétition à la mauvaise que
tous commencent à se rassembler c'est
qu'il ya beaucoup de personnes et c'est
un grand truc comme vous allez c'est du
gros choir dire qu'il ya une danse qui
es-tu de choc loison la première partie
qui est une danse que les bretons
adoptez aménagé pour eux et la deuxième
dans ce que l'on fait c'est une création
totale de nos adhérents plus d'une heure
de spectacle au coeur du xviie siècle
pour ceux qui n'auraient pas pu se
déplacer
séance de rattrapage à l'opéra royal
jeudi 17 mai
[Musique]